classé aujourd'hui des comédiens des
figurants dans prisonniers ennemis
sicario l'arrivée et blade runner 2049
ça en fait du monde à habiller c'est
dans son appartement du plateau mont
royal quand ce n'est pas sur un plateau
de tournage que rené a pris la dessiner
ses costumes pour les cinq derniers film
de denis villeneuve
il fut un temps où l'on produisait une
aquarelle pour chaque costume
la tablette a remplacé l'aquarelle c'est
pour aller vite c'est pour élever ses
points et ça va beaucoup plus vite c'est
vrai que c'est moins beau qu une
aquarelle
soyons honnêtes l'aquarelle c'est beau
mais c'est vraiment plus rapide et
rapide il faut l'être quand on travaille
sur la suite de blade runner et qu'il
faut produire des centaines de costumes
pour le seul manteau porté par ryan
gosling
il a fallu fabriquer 15 versions
différentes une progression dans le
manteau yanis boy déchets et couper sa
personne en prend bien deuxième équipe
tient stone tient photo un cascadeur
puisque c'est moi un photo d'abord alors
s'attendre en tête les preneurs budget
180 millions le tournage une sorte de
tempête féroce en plein océan qui nous
permet d'apprécier la qualité du travail
du capitaine du navire
denis villeneuve grande qualité de
données ces plateaux sont agréables le
monde est fin le monde se respecte c'est
tenir respectueux et y appelle respect
les acteurs sont tellement contents
d'être c'est vrai parce que souvent le
succès annoncé
c'est tellement vrai que je dis je ferai
pas cinq films avec un reza taqipour
respectueux et pied pour faire son
appartement de montréal et paisible bien
décorée mais rené a pris le niez pas
souvent au cours des dix dernières
années
à peine 5 en partie par exemple dix mois
pour blade runner
dis-moi playground ah ben oui à
l'extérieur oui popcap est oui oui
réseau nier sept mois tu l'entends
géorgie sicario aussi c'est moi bürgi au
nouveau mexique
alors quand vous revenez chez vous s'est
longtemps partie mais il y adhérer
content ouais ouais mon moment préféré
ce que j'aime le plus dans la vie c'est
faire des essais c'est le moment magique
c'est avec les avec les comédiens tu es
dans une petite pièce un miroir raid de
consulter les confections et le thé
c'est et tu crées personnages ensemble
c'est des moments que jada en 2012 à
québec le musée de l'amérique française
a présenté une exposition consacrée aux
oeuvres de rené april parce que mine de
rien au cours de sa carrière elle a
travaillé sur une quarantaine de
productions rené april avec son talent
son expérience a le luxe de pouvoir
choisir avec qui elle va travailler moi
c'est le résultat c'est la rencontre
avec le réalisateur pas pour rien que ça
fait cinq films de chevet avec denis
villeneuve pas ce qui est exceptionnel
exceptionnel au point deux récolté huit
nominations aux oscars l'an dernier avec
l'arrivée le mois prochain on saura si
le nouveau blade runner se retrouvera
sur la liste des nominations des oscars
2010 8h40 peut-être cette fois-ci pas
quoi mais je pense qu'il ya d'autres
défis non non non non non le couple est
déjà parent quand j'ai été invité à
faire partie de l'académie ça j'en suis
très fier et donc au bout du comptoir
une fois par année
rené a pris le va aussi faire comme les
6000 autres membres de l'académie du
cinéma des arts et des sciences
elle va voter pour choisir les gagnants
des oscars
pas mal du tout pour une petite fille
native de rivière du loup